[MUSIC PLAYING]
MURMAN: Good afternoon.
My name is Earll Murman.
On behalf of the Department of
Aeronautics and Astronautics
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
and the New England
section of the American
Institute of Aeronautics
and Astronautics,
I'd like to welcome you to the
25th Lester Gardner lecture.
Lester Gardner was a graduate
of the class of 1898,
an air officer in
World War I, publisher
of aviation literature, a leader
of the aeronautics profession,
and an enthusiast for
aeronautical engineering.
In his will, he
bequeathed a gift
to sponsor an annual lecture
on the history of aeronautics.
With today's lecture
marking the 25th anniversary
year of the landing
on the moon, we
are expanding the theme of
the Lester Gardner lecture
to include astronautics.
If Academy Awards were to be
given for this half century's
greatest achievements,
the Apollo program
certainly would be
nominated for an Oscar.
And today's speakers would be
nominated for the best producer
and the best leading performer.
Dr. Robert C. Seamans Jr.,
a researcher, engineer,
skillful administrator,
professor, dean of engineering,
and outstanding gentlemen
will be the first speaker.
A graduate of Harvard
and MIT, Dr. Seamans
joined NASA as
associate administrator
in 1960, after
research and teaching
at the instrumentation lab--
now the Charles Stark
Draper Laboratories--
at MIT and five years with RCA.
In his position as
associate administrator
and then deputy administrator
of NASA until 1968,
he oversaw the historic
Mercury, and Gemini,
and Apollo programs.
After leaving NASA, he served
as Secretary of the Air Force,
President of the National
Academy of Engineering,
administrator of the energy
research and development
administration agency,
and Professor and Dean
of Engineering at MIT.
His lovely wife, Jean,
his partner for 52 years
during this illustrious
career is also with us today--
Jean.
[APPLAUSE]
Midway through this
lecture, Dr. Seamans
will pass the podium to Neil
Armstrong, engineer, combat
and test pilot, astronaut,
professor, businessmen,
and role model for a generation
of youth around the world.
A graduate of Purdue
and USC, Mr. Armstrong
joined NASA as a test pilot
after serving in Korea.
In 1962, he transferred
to the astronaut corps
and was the commander in 1966 of
the Gemini 8 flight, the first
to accomplish docking in space.
His Gemini partner was
David Scott, a graduate
of our department here at MIT.
Mr. Armstrong is known
throughout the world
for the words, "That's
one small step for man,
one giant step for
mankind," which
he spoke as the first human to
step on the moon on July 20th,
1969.
His hiking partner on
the Apollo 11 expedition,
Dr. Buzz Aldrin, Jr., also a
graduate of our department,
is here with us today.
Buzz, can you--
[APPLAUSE]
After leaving NASA-- sorry, Buzz
I have to cut off the applause.
After leaving NASA
in 1971, Neil has
been a Professor of
Aerospace Engineering
at the University of
Cincinnati and is presently
chairman of AIL Systems, Inc.,
an electronics manufacturer.
25 years ago, the attention of
the world was focused on a race
to put man on the moon.
Such a feat seemed
unbelievable to most humans.
Today, mankind debates the
wisdom of manned space program
and the priorities
for its funding.
But since Neil and Buzz walked
on the moon, how many times
have we all heard someone say,
if we can put a man on the moon
why can't we--
whatever the problem is.
The Apollo program stands as
the benchmark for what mankind
can accomplish and a challenge
to all those who follow.
Today we will hear just how
difficult this challenge was
as our speakers tell us about
engineering aspects of a lunar
landing.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Seamans to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
SEAMANS: Neil and
I flipped a coin.
I'm going to take
the left hand side,
and he's going to
take the right.
[LAUGHTER]
It's certainly a
great honor for me
to be involved with
the Gardner lecture
and to be on the
podium with Neil.
And I can honestly say that
it wouldn't have happened
if it hadn't been for my former
boss, my first boss, my mentor
for 15 years here at
the Institute, a person
by the name of Doc Draper.
Now Doc, on
occasion, used to use
the analogy of fire engines,
their power, their speed,
their energy, when
Air Force or Navy
brass, complete with
entourages, would visit the lab.
He'd say, we're
nothing but little boys
on the sidewalk watching
the fire engines go by.
And at this point,
I'm going to show you
what Doc liked to do best.
Doc loved to work
with equipment.
He also liked people.
But nothing better for Doc than
to have a new design coming
along, to test it, to try it,
to take it up in an aeroplane,
or put it through its paces.
And here you see my
mentor, Doc Draper,
up on the roof of his
laboratory checking out
the guidance and
navigation system that was
to be used going to the moon.
And in the distance, you
can recognize the Longfellow
Bridge.
You can see the
Prudential Building
Now, in the late 1950s,
NASA had reminded
me very much of Doc's analogy.
Keith Glennan, the fire
chief up front, Bob Gilruth,
there he was manning
the life support vehicle
for the seven astronauts.
Wernher Von Braun was
driving the hook and ladder.
Fortunately, he had
[? Eberhart ?] Reese
back on the rear of the hook
and ladder to keep on the road.
He was a chief engineer.
Other engines were driven by
people like Abe Silverstein
and Tommy Thompson and all the
various directors and program
managers.
There were a lot of engines.
And there were a lot
of fires to put out.
Now I was one of the small boys
watching the armada approach
one day, and sort
of wishing I was
aboard when all of a
sudden, Keith Glennan, who
was the fire chief, he
swerved over the curb.
And he opened the door.
And he invited me to ride
along with him and Dr. Dryden.
I asked about what's
really going on.
What's the rush?
Why all this energy?
What capabilities were needed?
Before obtaining all
the answers, Keith left.
And Jim Webb became the chief.
The fire intensified.
It was no longer
merely a 10 alarm fire.
New facilities and kinds
of equipment were required.
We had only eight years
to meet a major deadline
of landing men on the moon and
returning them safely to Earth.
Now we know we met the
deadline-- although sometimes,
I'll have to admit, when
I see the moon coming up
over the horizon, I really
wonder if it actually happened.
And I also find
it sometimes hard
to believe that it took
place 25 years ago.
I mean, Neil and Buzz
haven't changed a bit.
[LAUGHTER]
But the magnitude of the effort
required to achieve this goal
was so great that no single
person could possibly
observe the total endeavor.
I say this because--
there may be differing views
of the mission, and so on--
but after all, there were
400,000 people involved.
And there were many
different jobs to be done.
Now you're about to hear two
accounts discussing the program
from an engineering standpoint.
When I joined NASA in
the late summer of 1960,
the agency was
$400 million apart
from President Eisenhower's view
of what we should be getting.
Keith Glennan met with Maury
Stands, director of OMB,
soon after I arrived to reclamor
60 million of the $400 million
difference.
Stands laughed at the idea.
In desperation, Keith asked,
what do you want in space?
And Stands replied,
a bargain basement
figure-- $1.09 billion.
Sometime later at
a cabinet meeting,
George Kistiakowsky, who was
the present science advisor,
presented the result
of a study that
indicated the cost of
manned lunar landing
would be between
$20 and $40 billion.
After the gasping
subsided around the table,
Eisenhower said, I wish
someone could tell me the best
$1 billion program for space.
After Jim Webb became chief
I joined him in a visit
to the new director
of OMB, Dave Bell.
We made a pitch for Saturn
boosters and the Apollo
manned exploration beyond the
existing manned, operating
on a shoestring, Mercury.
When we proposed design studies
for Apollo, there was no sale.
And it was no sale
a few days later
when we met with
President Kennedy.
However, Gagarin's
flight around the world
in one hour and 48
minutes a month later
raised anew the question, why
was the USA so far behind?
The Congress went crazy
looking for a scapegoat.
Why wasn't NASA
working 24 hours a day
to get ahead of the Soviets?
And let me say, at
that time, people
were working darn near
24 hours of the day
to get Mercury into orbit.
President Kennedy had
wanted to hear the evidence
before weighing in on
new space initiatives.
However, the evidence
had become clear.
Whether by luck or
careful planning
the Soviets had scored big
in the international arena.
And Kennedy didn't propose
hauling up the white flag.
But which goals would permit
the US to gain greater respect
in future years?
Some counseled against
further manned space
in favor of intensified
scientific research
here on Earth or in space.
Kennedy reached out beyond the
staff to Vice President Johnson
and ultimately to McNamara,
Secretary of Defense,
and to Jim Webb for the answers.
Now if I can find the
right button-- here we go.
What you have here is
that Mercury vehicle
up on top of the
Redstone booster.
This was really a wing and
a prayer type operation.
It was the vehicle
that was being prepared
for Alan Shepard at the Cape.
Behind it you see
the very large gantry
which sort of
overpowers it, which
was backed off so that
some tests could be run.
But when work was to be done on
either Redstone or the Mercury
vehicle, it would be
rolled up into place.
Now with some foreboding,
the White House
allowed the Mercury
suborbital flight to proceed.
And on May 5th, Alan Shepard
became a world figure
by traveling 630 miles
downrange in 15 minutes.
The Webb-McNamara meeting that
took place at the Pentagon
the following day had the
benefit of the world reaction
to Shepard's completely
open televised flight.
It was agreed by the two of
them that all missions should
be conducted openly
and also that prestige
was a valid national goal.
It was felt that the
Soviets would soon be
able to fly with multiple crew.
And that proved to be correct.
They might soon be able
to actually fly out
around the moon, or even
go into circumlunar flight
around the moon.
But it was also believed
that they would not
have the capability
for an extended period,
and with new equipment, to
actually land on the moon.
So at this point,
let me just show
you what happened at just about
the time that this report was
to be handed in to the
Vice President Johnson
and then to Kennedy,
there was a meeting out
in the back of the White House
where President Kennedy gave
Alan Shepard the highest
award that NASA can give.
And behind Alan is
his beautiful wife.
Now thanks, in part, to the
success of Shepard's flight,
the President and Vice
President accepted the goal,
as did the Congress
following President Kennedy
State of the Union
address on May 25th, 1961.
Now to achieve this
goal, policy issues
had to be resolved, and quickly.
And one of them had to do
with NASA personnel buildup.
And a decision was made
that the necessary buildup
and capability
around the country
would not come by
increasing substantially
the number of people at NASA.
Rather, major support
would be required
from many other departments
and agencies of government--
the Air Force, for example,
played a major role--
from a large number
of contractors--
and I forget the number,
but it was staggering--
and from foreign nations,
particularly those nations
that were located where we
wanted to put large tracking
antennas.
Now the space task group, which
had been 1,000 strong down
at Langley Field where the
astronauts were being trained,
and where the design of the
Mercury was taking place,
was move to Houston, Texas and
became the Manned Spacecraft
Center, and now the
Johnson Flight Center.
New operations were started
in New Orleans for assembling
the first stages of
the Saturn booster,
and in Mississippi for
testing large rocket engines
and boosters.
A tremendous amount
of engineering
was required, obviously.
I believe it's true that every
engineering discipline was
brought into play, from pile
driving in the Florida sands
to support what was to
become the second largest
building in the world to a
study of orbital mechanics
for transfer of astronauts from
lunar landing to, for example,
the orbiting craft going around
the moon-- with Mike Collins
aboard, as it turned out.
Now I'm going to
discuss for you three
aspects of the engineering
decisions that had to be made--
first, the mode
selection for achieving
lunar landing and
return, second,
the method for assembly and
checkout at Cape Canaveral,
and third, the strategy for
evolving developmental hardware
into flight-ready
launch vehicles
as rapidly as possible,
and as safely and reliably
as possible.
Neil, on the other
hand, is going
to talk about the design
requirements for the lunar
landing.
He'll get into the subject
of the rocket engines.
He'll get into guidance
and navigation as well
as the subject of
training and of simulation
and the special aids that
were required for the crew
before they made their
first of a kind mission.
So now turning to
the mission itself
and how it was to
be accomplished,
the favored mode in those
days followed the Jules Verne
script of a takeoff with
all equipment aboard.
In this version,
called direct ascent,
you peeled off booster
stages as you required
more and more acceleration.
So this happened as
the trip progressed,
arriving back home
aboard the capsule that
had been a home away from
home for the whole journey.
A variant on this
approach involved
placing the hardware and
propellants in Earth orbit
through a series of
two or more launches.
Several stages, or modules,
could be launched separately,
connected together
in Earth orbit
after rendezvous and
docking, much as the space
station has been planned today.
The astronauts, once
they were in Earth orbit,
would then proceed to the moon
and back just as though they'd
taken off direct ascent.
However, there was
a strategy proposed
by John Hubalt, the
NASA research engineer,
which was quite different.
In this mode, the astronauts
travel to the moon
with two separate habitats.
One spacecraft would stay
in orbit around the moon.
The other, the
lunar lander, would
separate from the spacecraft
to land on the moon.
After visiting
the lunar surface,
the astronauts would lift off
from the moon, rendezvous,
and transfer to the
return spacecraft.
What did this seemingly more
complex, and possibly more
dangerous, approach
have to offer?
You know, supposing you
don't rendezvous and dock?
The obvious answer was to
limit the launch requirement.
The return spacecraft
required a heavy heat shield
to protect the astronauts
during high speed reentry.
The requirement to land,
then accelerate the return
spacecraft back
into lunar orbit,
if we'd done it
that way, would have
doubled the size of
the launch vehicle
at takeoff from Cape Canaveral.
More detailed design brought
out additional advantages.
The lunar lander could be
configured for maneuverability
and crew visibility
in the vacuum
and to approach the moon, where
the visibility was clearly
very important.
And Neil will be discussing
that with you shortly.
But obviously, all was
lost if the astronauts
failed to rendezvous.
I didn't say dock,
because the astronauts
were trained to transfer
the return capsule by EVA--
extra vehicular activity--
if docking failed.
And the return
vehicle would also
be maneuvered for a rendezvous
if the lunar lander happened
to run out of gas or
something went wrong assuming
it was up in orbit.
These aspects of the mission
were practiced extensively
on Gemini missions
that preceded Apollo
and in simulated Apollo flights.
At one flight, Gemini 6
rendezvoused with Gemini 7.
But we flipped the numbers.
It was much more fun to talk
about the 76 mission rather
than the 67 mission.
Here you see Gemini 7 with Frank
Borman and Jim Lovell aboard.
And they took off from a pad.
They were going to fly
for 14 days anyway.
And the idea was that
in about seven days,
if we work post-haste,
night and day,
we could get Gemini 6 and
its titan booster on the pad.
And it could take off.
And we could demonstrate
rendezvous but not docking.
Well, obviously
this did take place.
There was a little
trouble at the takeoff.
We had to delay
a couple of days.
But they not only were able
to come reasonably close--
they differ as to
how close they came,
but I believe the measurement
was made in centimeters.
Now, the extra
vehicular was actually
tested first on Gemini 4.
And here you see Ed White
outside the capsule.
And he found that
once he got outside,
he had a little hand
rocket gun, and he
could aim it in
different directions
and move back and forth.
And the idea here
was that if all else
failed, if he didn't
dock, it would
be possible for the
transfer to take place
by going out of one capsule
and coming into the other.
Now finally, the
added risk had to be
viewed in the context
of total risk,
weighing the pros of a
smaller launch vehicle at Cape
Canaveral, maneuverability
and visibility near the moon,
and the advantage of two
inhabitable vehicles, each
with its own life support,
against the greater
risk associated with rendezvous
of two vehicles in orbit
around the moon.
Now there were many
differing views on this,
both within and without
NASA, let me say.
And Brainerd Holmes, who
headed the manned program
at that time, and Joe Shea,
the systems architect who
worked with him, ran
all kinds of analyses
to try to get a
better feel for which
was the best of these
mission approaches.
And while all this was going
on, and before a decision
had been made, President Kennedy
and Vice President Johnson
decided they'd like
to go and visit
the various centers
involved in the program.
And the first stop
was Huntsville.
And we ended up very early on
inside of the large assembly
hangar that's there.
And here you see the entourage
with President Kennedy
on the left.
You can see Vice President
Johnson looking a little gloomy
facing us.
And on his right is Jim Webb
talking to Wernher Von Braun.
There's a spy looking over
somebody's shoulder there.
[LAUGHTER]
And then you have Secretary of
Defense McNamara, Gary Wiesner
and Howard Brown.
Gary Wiesner at that time was
President Kennedy's science
advisor.
And Kennedy was very
interested in some
of the intellectual
aspects of things.
And right on the floor
here of this big building,
he started asking about the
pros and cons, the kind of thing
we've just been discussing.
And it was a roped off area.
And a whole bunch of
press and everything
on the other side of the rope.
And they could see this
earnest discussion.
And needless to say, there was
plenty of probing by the press
after this had taken place.
But when all the dust settled
and everything was taken
into account, reason prevailed.
And the Apollo
mission was conducted
by lunar orbit rendezvous.
Now all previous
space vehicles had
been assembled on a launch pad.
And when launched,
the ground team--
usually about 250 strong--
were as close as
you could get them.
And to have them close
and have it safe,
they had lots of reinforced
concrete over their heads.
So the only way they
could get information
as to what was
really going on was
by looking through a
submarine type telescope
or by reading a
whole bunch of dials.
And in order to proceed, you
had to take the vehicle stage
by stage--
the first stage on the pad,
then the next, and the next.
Hook them altogether.
Test it out.
And while you're
doing this, you might
have tremendous sandstorms,
rain, hail, lightning,
all kinds of things.
And it was just--
as we thought about
it and then we
tried to plan how we were going
to assemble the Saturn V, which
was many, many times
larger and more complex
than anything we'd
done before, it
was just daunting to think
of doing it out of doors.
And for that reason, we thought
we should assemble indoors.
But of course, then you run
up against the very obvious
problem of how you're
going to get it on the pad,
and also how are you
going to check it out?
And here you see the
Saturn V and the Apollo
on the transporter.
Now how did the transporter
come to look like that?
Incidentally, in
the distance, you
can see the vertical assembly
building, that very large
building I mentioned earlier.
Now in the past, when we moved
the gantry back and forth,
it ran on wheels.
And so we thought, why not.
We just put a lot of
track down, and wheels.
And no matter how
many wheels we put on,
we found that if you stopped
the transporter overnight you
had flats on the wheel the next
day, the loads were so great.
Then we thought, well,
we've got a lot of water
down at the Cape.
And we could just
build some canals.
And we'll float it out.
And there wasn't a
marine type engineer
who could figure out how to
keep the whole [INAUDIBLE]
stable if you tried it that way.
[LAUGHTER]
So things were starting
to look pretty bleak.
The whole concept of
an assembly building
appeared to be going out the
window when the Von Braun
team discovered
the enormous drag
lines that are used for surface
mining of coal in Appalachia.
The loads carried by the
caterpillar tractors--
and you can see perhaps
three or four of them there--
were carrying loads that
were comparable to what
Apollo's Saturn would weigh,
along with its umbilical tower,
and along with the
platform itself.
And the drag lines had
automatic leveling, obviously
an important feature, and
particularly important
since to get out to the
pad three miles away,
this whole assembly had to
go up a three degree slope.
However, the use
of a transporter
introduced other problems.
Until 1962, as I've
described, everybody
was in the block house.
And what you used there
for instrumentation
is what you used
practically at home.
You had thermometers, and
with wires perhaps coming out
inside, volt meters
to read, and so on.
But there was no way that
you could connect directly
from the sensors on the
Apollo and the Saturn directly
into the large control
here three miles away.
The solution necessitated
the conversion of analog
to digital signals.
Never before had so many sensors
and converters been required.
The same devices were to be used
for checkout and for launching,
which was also important.
At launch, on the
order of 70,000 signals
were automatically verified
during the final two minutes
before liftoff.
And if the signals were
not within tolerance,
the launch crew would
investigate and determine
whether to scrub, or
continue, or hold.
Extensive digital processing
and computing equipment
was installed in the
base of the transporter
to provide all the necessary
information for the checkout
and launch crews whether
the vehicle was in assembly
or sitting on the launch pad.
And you can see their
individual consoles.
And at each console
you had somebody
who was a specialist
in a particular area
that the instruments
were measuring.
And if anything appeared
to be out of tolerance,
the light would go on to
tell a fella to get alert,
or the gal to get alert.
And by means of the
computer, and so on,
you could zero in and
find what the fault was.
Or if you couldn't
find it, you certainly
were going to hold or scrub.
If you could find it,
there were occasions
that something would be
slightly over tolerance
and you could go ahead.
Now the last item
I want to discuss
is what are called
all up testing.
Technologies enters into design
decisions in many obvious ways.
But it also affects
optimal developments, often
in subtle fashion.
Rocket propelled vehicles have
experienced many failures prior
to success.
Going back to the
beginning, I understand
it was the 71st firing of the
V2 before the Germans achieved
success at Peenemunde, and thank
goodness that was the case.
As a consequence, the
planning for the Saturn,
with the Von Braun
team in charge,
called for four launches
of the first stage
before going to the second
stage so that you'd get
the first stage under control.
And then you'd move
on to the next.
Now all four were successful.
And by the time Saturn,
or as it was called SA3,
and SA4 came along.
The press got wind of this.
We had quite a
time with the media
explaining why we had
to spend all this money
to carry tons of sand
across the Atlantic Ocean.
Because that's about all
we were accomplishing.
Now just prior to
the launching of SA5,
President Kennedy, who
was staying at Palm Beach,
said he'd like to
come over and see
how things were going on with
his friend Senator Smathers.
And here you see him.
That's a member of the Secret
Service behind Wernher Von
Braun.
And here you see
President Kennedy.
And President Kennedy is
pointing up at the SA5.
And a model of it was
used for explanation.
And that's right next to Werner.
And if you want to
see it in the flesh,
you can go over to the
Kennedy Library, where
that very same model now rests.
But what we were explaining
to President Kennedy
was that the next
launching, which
actually occurred
about six weeks later,
had a live upper stage.
It's called the S4 stage for
very complicated reasons,
but it's really
the second stage.
It would be the first time
that we'd tried in a major way
to make use of
hydrogen as a fuel.
Now you can see that if we
were going to proceed step
by step this way,
we had a long road
to go before we got to a full
scale launching with astronauts
aboard of the Saturn
V. Now George Miller,
when he came aboard,
answered these questions
in a dramatic fashion.
He stated we couldn't reach
our goal step by step.
We must test as much hardware
as possible on each mission.
All up testing
became the watchword.
The first flight of Saturn
V included all three rocket
stages and the Apollo capsule
with its service module.
The official designation
was Apollo 4 AS501.
All systems were
go at large right
on time November 4th, 1967--
nobody aboard, of course.
And all continued to perform
essentially perfectly
during the entire flight.
And there you see the first
launch of the Apollo Saturn.
And the bottom
has almost reached
the top of the umbilical tower.
You can see those
swing arms that
are back away from the vehicle.
And this is at the point when,
since the three mile distance
to the spectators and to
the large control, when
you could first hear the
sound of those rocket motors.
And it was really intense.
When I say hear, you didn't
just hear them with your ears.
You could feel it in your chest.
You felt it all over.
The roar of those engines
and the vibrations
were really fantastic.
But the principle of
all up systems testing
was established by this
daring but essential plan made
possible by greatly improved
component reliability
and comprehensive testing.
It was one of the
reasons that we had,
of course, the
Mississippi test facility.
Now as I have mentioned
earlier, Neil Armstrong
will discuss certain engineering
aspects of the lunar landing
from quite a different
perspective than mine.
Neil's view was that of a very
interested and technically
minded user.
[LAUGHTER]
He was the first to conduct
a successful docking
when he piloted Gemini 8
and docked with the Agena.
And that's a whole
story in itself.
And that was a very
exciting experience.
He ended up spinning, when
the thing went out of control,
at two revolutions a second.
And he pulled his way out of it.
He then landed eagle in
the Sea of Tranquility
with Buzz Aldrin at his side.
They worked together
as a team, obviously,
followed by a docking with Mike
Collins aboard the Apollo 11
spacecraft in lunar orbit.
And then he went through
a very high speed reentry
to return back into
the Earth's atmosphere.
And for his remarkable skills,
demonstrated live before
millions of people, he earned
the privilege of addressing
august groups like the
one I'm showing you here--
a joint session of Congress.
And here you see Neil,
with Buzz on the right,
Mike on the left, Vice President
Agnew, and Speaker McCormack.
And now the shoe is
on the other foot.
We here are privileged
to have Neil with us
today to tell us some
of the engineering
aspects of his flight.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ARMSTRONG: Thank you.
Thank you.
That's a very kind welcome.
And I'm most appreciative.
I'm appreciative to be asked
to give the Gardner lecture.
As I look on the
back of your program
at the list of
former lecturers, I'm
struck that there are some
of the most able and creative
leaders in aviation and
aerospace in our history.
And I'm honored that
Bob and I would be asked
to add our names to that list.
Bob said I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the engineering
aspects of the lunar landing.
And you can, of course,
find 1,000 kinds
of engineering challenges
and solutions to talk about.
So I thought I would
highlight just that part
of the flight which was involved
in getting from lunar orbit
to the surface of the moon.
The requirements were
relatively simple.
Begin in lunar orbit, and
end up parked on the surface,
hopefully in a suitable
condition to take off again.
[LAUGHTER]
It was desirable to be able to
land at a preselected location
without runways, without
control towers, beacons,
or any other aids
on the surface.
Each of the sites that
we would like to go to
would be selected to investigate
different types of lunar
topography, to photograph
and sample the highlands,
and the craters, and the mare.
I can see if the
lights [INAUDIBLE]..
After selecting a landing site,
its longitude and latitude
could be accurately determined
from lunar maps drawn
from astronomical photographs.
Elevations relative to
the mean surface level
was considerably less certain.
A landing site near the equator
certainly has advantages.
Equatorial orbits would pass
over or near the landing area
on every revolution and
would give the flight planner
a good deal of flexibility.
Because the landing
site must lie
underneath the orbital
path, or near it,
a site well north or
south of the equator
requires an inclined orbit.
The moon's rotation
about its axis
is about a half a
degree per hour.
And so the landing site is
always moving toward or away
from an inclined orbit,
adding constraints
to the trajectory plan.
The fact that
Earth-based radar could
provide accurate spacecraft
position and velocity
information at lunar distance
was a substantial engineering
achievement.
Of course, the
rotation of the Earth
meant that the radar itself was
moving at substantial speed.
Additionally, half
of the time, it
was on the side of the
Earth away from the moon
and could not be utilized.
So three giant radars were used,
more or less equally spaced
around the Earth so that
at least one of them
was always located in a
position to give good coverage
of the spacecraft.
Because the entire orbit around
the moon subtended only a half
a degree as seen from
Earth, some amount
of tracking time and
mathematical smoothing
was required to establish an
accurate value for the three
orthogonal components
of position
and the three orthogonal
components of velocity.
These six vectors, with
the associated time tag,
was known as the spacecraft
state or state vector.
It could be accurately
determined and projected
ahead in coasting
flight, but was
unable to keep up whenever
the spacecraft was
changing its trajectory
due to rocket thrust.
In 1966, the trajectory
planners were
given an unwelcome surprise.
It happened during the
flight of an American robot
spacecraft named Lunar
Orbiter, the first craft
to fly around the moon.
Its orbit, as recorded by the
giant radars here on Earth,
had some peculiar wiggles in it.
Whenever the spacecraft flew
over one of the dark areas,
or Mare, it was attracted
inward toward the moon.
The only known cause
for such a phenomenon
would be an extraordinarily
strong gravitational pull
due to the very heavy spots
on the moon's surface.
These mass concentrations,
or mascons,
were mapped by analyzing the
orbit of the lunar orbiters,
and later by mapping
the orbit of Apollo
8, the first manned craft to fly
around the moon, which occurred
during the Christmas of
1968, and again on Apollo 10,
the lunar landing
dress rehearsal.
These orbit wiggles
were quite pronounced,
indicating that the mascons were
quite near the lunar surface.
There was substantial
concern that
these gravitational
uncertainties
would preclude landing
at a precise location
on the surface.
NASA's landing trajectory
specialists in Houston
ran many trajectories
with varying levels
of mascon influence.
They concluded that the mascon
effects were acceptable.
Additionally, they
considered dispersions
in inertial guidance, alignment,
and rocket engine performance.
Two possible conditions
were to be considered--
a successful completion of the
landing or a discontinuance
of the approach during
the descent for any one
of a variety of reasons.
The dispersions
should not prevent
the successful
execution of either.
In the case of the
abort back to orbit,
the dispersion should
not put the lunar module
in a trajectory that would
make a subsequent rendezvous
with the command
module impossible.
The rocket engine to be used
in the descent was critical.
There would be a
substantial advantage
in using a minimum
weight system.
Weight was at a real premium,
as Bob has discussed.
That would dictate high chamber
pressure and high energy
propellants.
Top candidates would be liquid
hydrogen as the fuel and liquid
oxygen as the oxidizer.
These propellants
were cryogenic-- that
is, they had to be kept
at very low temperatures
to maintain the liquid phase.
And it was a four
day trip to the moon.
And there was a chance of
substantial evaporative loss
during the trip.
An alternate possibility was
to use propellants that were
liquid at normal temperatures--
fuel such as alcohol,
or kerosene, hydrazine,
oxidizers such as hydrogen
peroxide or nitrogen tetroxide.
The combination that
eventually was selected
was a hydrazine UDMH blend
as the fuel and nitrogen
tetroxide as the oxidizer.
Now both of those are liquid
at normal atmospheric pressures
and temperatures.
But they're very toxic
and nasty to work with.
They had been in common use for
rockets for decades, however.
And their nature,
however unpleasant
was well known and understood.
The combination had an
important advantage.
They were hypergolic--
that is, the fuel burned
whenever it came in
contact with the oxidizer.
They were self-igniting.
So there was no
need for spark plugs
or other special ignition
devices, or other systems.
Additionally, the combination
had reasonable specific impulse
or energy efficiency at
relatively low chamber
pressures.
That permitted a
pressure-fed rocket
that did not require the weight
and complexity of a turbo pump
to boost the pressure.
The resulting combination
was conceptually
simple and reliable.
However, there was
one other requirement
that was everything but simple.
Somehow, this rocket needed
to provide a wide variation
in thrust.
To efficiently decelerate
from orbital velocity
required a high thrust level.
Landing required a
relatively low thrust level.
Orbital speed in lunar orbit
is approximately 5,500 feet
per second.
Now some of you will be
surprised by my archaic use
of English units.
[LAUGHTER]
Although metric or SI
was used in a few places,
in NASA in those
days English units
were the predominant standard.
And because this is an
engineering history lecture,
I'll use the English units
that were the norm at the time.
Using Newton's law--
the second law--
and the definition of
rocket specific impulse,
one can readily
determine the propellant
required to decelerate a mass
from orbit to zero velocity.
We'll leave it as an
exercise for the student.
[LAUGHTER]
For the lunar case, each pound
to be delivered to the surface
requires slightly
more than a pound
of our selected propellant.
So the initial weight in
orbit must be more than twice
the landing weight.
When the craft was landing
or hovering above the surface
preparing to land,
the thrust would
need to be equal to the landing
weight plus some modulation
to allow for increasing and
reducing the rate of descent
while maneuvering for landing.
Most rocket engines of
that era were operated
at essentially fixed thrust.
Throttle-able engines
were very rare.
And those that had
been tried had far less
modulation than
would be necessary.
The engineering challenge
was substantial.
Two contending
approaches were tried.
One concept inserted inert
gas into the propellant line
between the tanks and the
rocket so that the thrust
would be reduced
while the total flow
rates through the
combustion chamber
would be constant at all times.
The competing idea used a
mechanical throttling system
using cavitating venturi
flow control valves.
That engine, which was built
by STL, later to become TRW,
was selected for
the lunar module.
But actually, both approaches
worked quite well--
surprisingly well.
The engine had a maximum
thrust of 10,000 pounds
and could be modulated between
1,000 and 6,000 pounds.
The thrust needed to
hover before landing
was about 2,500 pounds.
And the variation available,
then, 1,000 to 6,000,
was adequate for that task.
In the thrust range
between maximum thrust
and the throttling range,
the cavitating venturis
would be intermittently
cavitating or not
and produce an
unpredictable mixture ratio.
That thrust range
was prohibited to us
due to the probability
of excessive erosion
of the nozzle.
Simplicity and reliability
were selected over performance.
The rocket used a simple
pressure-fed system.
The propellants were pushed
into the rocket by gas pressure.
Helium stored in a supercritical
state at about 1,600 PSI,
and that was used to pressurize
the tanks at about 235 PSI.
Maximum chamber pressure
in the combustion chamber
was a remarkably low 103
PSI at maximum thrust,
and considerably less
in the throttling range.
There were many engineering
accomplishments in the Apollo
program, but many believe
the descent engine was
one of the most outstanding.
For guidance,
navigation, and control,
the lunar module had an inertial
guidance system designed here
at the Draper Lab,
which at that time
was called the
Instrumentation Laboratory.
The system included
a three degree
of freedom inertial measurement
unit and a digital computer.
The IMU was the
navigation sensor,
using accelerometers and gyros
to sense attitude and velocity
changes.
The computer, which included
the navigation logic
for calculating the
guidance commands,
was a 70 pound 16-bit machine.
It had 36K of ROM
and woven rope cores.
It had no color monitor, not
even a black and white monitor,
no alphanumerics.
All communication to
and from the operator
was through three
registers of seven digits--
two for identification
and five for data.
By today's workstation
standards, or even
in comparison with a Mac or a
PC, it was a primitive device.
But it was far
advanced over anything
we had had up to that time.
And we were delighted to have
it even though it cost more
than a small country.
[LAUGHTER]
The orbital altitude selected
to initiate the powered descent
was 50,000 feet.
Descents from altitude
above 50,000 feet
required increasing
amounts of propellant,
and altitudes below 50,000 feet
increasingly reduced safety
margins.
Altitude errors in
either direction
could prevent guidance
equations from converging
and would prevent a
successful landing.
The moon, of course,
has no atmosphere.
The normal flight instruments
of an aircraft-- the altimeter,
airspeed indicator, mach
meter, rate of climb--
are all atmospheric
sensing devices
and will not
operate in a vacuum.
But clearly, such information,
directly measured,
would be of considerable
use to the crew.
So a specially designed radar
attached to the lunar module
was used to determine
altitude and velocity.
The landing radar
directed four beams
to the lunar surface, a
three beam Doppler velocity
sensor and one beam for the
determination of slant range.
With the appropriate
coordinate transformations,
the results could be
converted into altitude
and three components
of velocity,
all relative to the surface.
Because the radar
beams were traversing
an irregular, and even
mountainous surface,
the radar data was jumping
and required some smoothing
within the guidance computer.
And I've mentioned a lot about
two guys at the Draper Lab
or the Instrumentation Lab who
were in large way responsible--
Dick Batten and George Cherry.
Dick's here today.
And many of you here
today, I'm sure,
helped Dick and George
with those projects.
And we remember that work very
well, and with a great deal
of respect.
The descent trajectory was
divided into three parts--
the braking phase, the approach
phase, and the landing phase.
The braking phase was intended
to provide deceleration
from orbital velocity
down to something
under 1,000 feet per second.
The best fuel efficiency
dictate that that
be conducted at maximum
thrust, as we've discussed.
The breaking phase covered
slightly more than 200 miles
in about 8 and 1/2 minutes.
The last two minutes utilized
the lower throttling region
of the engine to
allow for corrections
of dispersions in engine
thrust and trajectory.
The braking phase was designed
to place the lunar module
at about 4 1/2 miles short of
the landing site at an altitude
of about 7,000 feet.
From this point, the
approach phase was initiated.
Here the crew should be able
to pick up visual contact
with the planned landing site.
The guidance logic, which
could be characterized
as a downrange
acceleration command, which
was a quadratic
function of time,
was designed to
bring the craft down
to 500 feet just short
of the landing point.
From this point,
the autopilot could
complete an automatic
touchdown or the crew
could maneuver to the
preferred landing location.
In actuality, the crews
were reluctant to commit
to an automatic landing.
The autopilot had no
way of picking out
the smoothest landing area.
And it was not protected
against landing
with one landing pad
sticking in a crater.
Analytical studies had indicated
7% of automatic landings
would overturn on touchdown.
[LAUGHTER] So it's
not surprising
that the Apollo landings
were flown manually.
Now, I put this diagram in
because when I was teaching,
these are the quality of
the slides I used to use.
[LAUGHTER] Because of
the reduced gravity,
a machine hovering over the
moon, as shown in the middle
there, would require only
1/6 of the vertical thrust
it would need hovering over
Earth, as on the left side.
So while slowing to a
hover, the forward component
of that thrust is consequently
only 1/6 of its value on Earth.
And likewise, the
deceleration is only 1/6.
So to obtain the same
translational acceleration
or deceleration as you would
get on Earth on the left that
requires attitude
changes, as shown
on the far right side,
that are approximately
six times larger than
would be required on Earth.
Traversing large pitch or
roll angles, of course,
either requires more time
or larger control powers.
It was expected that the
control characteristics
ideal here on Earth would not at
all be acceptable on the moon.
These concerns had been the
subject of much attention
in the years immediately
prior to the landing attempt.
A variety of studies and
simulations had been conducted.
Attitude changes in
roll, and pitch, in yaw
were assumed to be achieved
by the use of small attitude
control rockets.
In the ground-based
flight simulators,
pilots found that they
could control attitude well
with reaction control rockets.
But they encountered difficulty
in making precise landings
and eliminating residual
velocities at touchdown.
It was clear that something
nearer to the real flying
experience was needed.
Helicopters were tried.
They could hover.
And they could duplicate the
final lunar landing trajectory.
Unfortunately, they were
incapable of investigating
the problems of most concern.
They could neither
replicate the consequences
of the lunar gravity
or the handling
characteristics of reaction
control system machines.
Fortunately, there
were two projects
which very effectively filled
the void-- the Lunar Landing
Research Vehicle, LLRV, and the
Lunar Landing Research Facility
LLRF.
The LLRV was developed by
NASA's flight research center
at Edwards California and built
by the Bell Aircraft Company.
In the lunar simulation
mode, the turbo fan engine,
mounted in a double
gimbal, was aligned
to the local vertical
and the thrust adjusted
to 5/6 of the LLRV weight.
The equivalent of the
lunar module descent engine
was provided by a pair of
throttle-able 500 pound thrust
rockets fixed to the fuselage
outside the gimbal ring.
These were monopropellant
rockets using hydrogen peroxide
as a fuel.
The turbo fans angle
and thrust could
be modulated to compensate
for aerodynamic drag
so that the craft coasted as
if it were flying in a vacuum.
The LLRV had a very
lightweight structure
and encountered a variety of
interactions between controls
and low structural frequencies.
After a number of development
changes were incorporated,
this cleverly compensated
flying machine
actually managed to
closely duplicate
flying as if it
were over the moon,
and became a very useful
tool for understanding
the needs of flying in
the lunar environment.
At the NASA Langley
Research Center,
an alternate approach
to lunar simulation
was initiated in what they
called the Lunar Landing
Research Facility.
I don't have a slide, I'm sorry,
but you can imagine a craft
like one of those stick figures
I drew suspended by cables
from a large gantry crane.
The idea, again, was to
duplicate the lunar gravity
and control characteristics.
The method was to lower
the vehicle apparent weight
to its lunar equivalent
by lifting upward
on the vertical cables attached
to a traveling bridge crane.
And a complex
electrohydraulic system
kept the crane platform
directly over the machine
and with an upward
force equal to 5/6
of the vehicle weight,
even during translations,
and angular motions, and weight
changes during due to fuel
usage.
It had a wonderful combination
of structural cable stretch,
pendulous frequencies requiring
innovative compensation
techniques.
It, indeed, was a
mechanical engineer's dream.
[LAUGHTER]
The vehicle was
attached to the cables
through gimbal rings allowing
pitch, roll, and yaw motion
provided by hydrogen
peroxide rockets.
And the 1/6 vehicle weight
not lifted by the cable system
was lifted by a throttle-able
hydrogen peroxide
rocket fixed to the structure.
After the kinks were worked out,
it worked surprisingly well.
The flying volume, which was
about 180 feet high, 360 feet
long, and 42 feet
wide was somewhat
limiting for a pilot,
but adequate to give
a substantive introduction to
lunar flight characteristics.
Both the LLRV and the LLRF
were able to investigate
a wide range of control
characteristics.
Control system
parameters were varied
and optimum combinations
recommended, primarily
based on pilot opinion.
Both LLRV LLRF studies indicated
that much lower control powers
were acceptable than had been
expected based on VTOL aircraft
and helicopter experience.
It was a welcome surprise,
because low control powers
result in low attitude
control fuel consumption.
These and related
evaluations were
most useful in establishing
the actual lunar module control
configuration.
The final LEM attitude control
system was rate command,
attitude hold.
That is the control stick
commanded angular rate
in all three axes,
but when centered,
attitude was maintained.
Based on the studies I've
just been talking about,
pitch and roll control
power had been established
at eight degrees per second,
and maximum commanded
rates at 20 degrees per
second for the lunar module.
And that provided
handling qualities
that were remarkably good.
In the LLRV, here, the
rocket was directly
controlled by the throttle.
But the lunar module--
the real lunar module--
added an automatic throttle
that would modulate thrust to
maintain a constant descent
rate.
Workload was
substantially reduced
and gave the pilot more time
to concentrate on selecting
a suitable landing spot.
A number of concerns
regarding lunar flying
emerged that were
unrelated to the hardware.
For many decades,
astronomers were
mystified by the peculiar
reflective qualities
of the moon.
These are surprisingly large
changes in brightness and sun
angle and a very bright
spot along the sun line.
It was feared that
visibility, visual acuity,
and depth perception
during a lunar landing
could be severely degraded.
Throughout the Apollo
program development,
there were worries about
visibility degradations
due to dust clouds caused by
the high velocity rocket exhaust
impinging on the lunar surface.
Additionally, rough
country, a close horizon,
and a lack of a strong
sense of the vertical
were possible impediments
to precision flying.
The lunar module experienced
normal design evolution.
The cabin volume was changed
from spherical to cylindrical.
The landing legs were
reduced from five to four.
The window area was
substantially reduced.
And the seat was removed.
[LAUGHTER]
The standing pilot, or
trolley conductor cockpit,
reduced weight,
moved the pilot's eye
closer to the window,
improving visibility,
and improved the structure.
A cable restraint
system was devised
to keep the pilots in the
proper position in the cabin,
and to hold them secure
during landing loads.
The fears about being blinded
by the sun's reflection
were unfounded.
The bright spot was
there, but the human eye
is quite capable of
accommodating to it.
And it did not
hinder operations.
The initial flights landed
early in the lunar morning.
That provided long
shadows, which
improved depth perception.
Lunar dust, on the
other hand, proved
to be a substantial impediment.
The dust was found
not to erupt in clouds
as it would here on Earth.
It travels radially outward
from the exhaust impingement
area in horizontal
thin, flat sheets.
It's very logical
in the lunar vacuum.
But it's a most surprising
phenomenon to Earthlings.
When the rocket engine
stops, the dust immediately
disappears over the
horizon, leaving
a perfectly clear view
with no dust cloud
or other residual
effects of any sort.
As might be expected,
the dust quantity
varied from landing
site to landing site.
On Apollo 11, Buzz and I had
a dust sheet that was opaque,
and I would say disconcerting,
due to its rapid movement.
But boulders protruding
above it provided
benchmarks adequate for
estimating speed and altitude.
On Apollos 14, 16, and 17,
the dust was quite thin,
and permitted visual
reference to the surface.
On Apollos 12 and 15,
however, the surface
was completely obscured with
dust below 50 feet of altitude,
and the landings were completed
essentially on instruments.
All in all, in spite of
its ungainly appearance,
the lunar module was a
superb flying machine.
It was a credit to the
engineering profession
and to those Grumman, TRW,
Draper Lab, and the others
who created it.
I'm in the debt of
all those folks.
And I thank you all for the
chance to join you today.
[APPLAUSE]
MURMAN: I'm sure
our speakers would
be happy to take
a few questions,
if maybe I could invite
Bob and Neil to come back
to the podium.
And I'll sit down.
And I would like to ask
that those of you who
want to ask questions come
forward to the microphones,
because this is being televised
across the campus cable TV
system.
And we'll have a
couple of questions.
And then we'll conclude it.
AUDIENCE: Mr.
Armstrong, I'm wondering
if you were concerned at
all that the funding--
with funding levels for the
space program in this country
have left it in decline?
Or do you think that things
are moving along well
from your point of view?
ARMSTRONG: Well,
that's a question that
has to do with
history in the future.
And it's really a bit outside
the scope of this lecture.
But I would just say that
I think all of us that
have been involved in these
programs over the past quarter
century or so have been
very pleased with the things
we have accomplished.
We're a little disappointed
that more things aren't
being initiated and less new
projects are being supported.
But it's my hope that that's
a temporary situation.
The world is full of
hills and valleys.
And that will never change.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
feeling you have about where
funding should be directed?
Or is there any particular
program or other programs
that you think
should be priorities?
And then I promise
I'll let you get away.
ARMSTRONG: Well, I think
I feel comfortable arguing
in favor of any one of a
number of new elements.
I'm not going to use today
to pick one over the other.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
if you might be
able to recount some
of the last moments
up to the lunar landing.
Specifically, I understand
the radar picked up
a number of boulders
over your landing site.
And you had to hover
for quite a while,
and nearly ran out
of fuel, and almost
had to abort the mission.
I wonder if you could
recount how close you
were to aborting the mission
in some of those last moments?
ARMSTRONG: I'm not sure
you could all hear that,
but the question was directed
toward the final part
of the Apollo 11 landing
where we did have a--
[LAUGHTER]
--some amount of divergence
to keep our minds occupied.
Fortunately, Buzz was a
master on the computer.
And he was able to keep me from
worrying about that too much.
We were flying
into the computer--
the autopilot was
flying us into an area.
As I said, it couldn't
know where it was going.
And it picked a very rough
spot, a very large crater--
[LAUGHTER]
--about the size of
a football stadium.
And that would have been
scientifically interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think Buzz
and I both agreed
that on the first landing we
ought to pick something that
was a little less challenging.
And so we looked
for a smooth spot.
And that took us a while to
get over to a smooth spot.
And yeah, we did use up most
of the fuel that we had.
And yes, had we had to
fly very much farther,
we might have had to
abort back into orbit.
But I can't say that I really
was concerned about that,
because we were getting
to get down fairly
close to the surface.
And even if we ran
out of fuel, as long
as we had the attitude
control with the 1-6G why,
we thought we could
absorb that bump OK.
So I really believe
that it probably
wasn't a significant concern.
Although Buzz was worried about
everything on the vehicle.
I only had to worry
about one thing.
So I should ask him
to speak for himself.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
played Lunar Lander?
[LAUGHTER]
ARMSTRONG: I have
to admit I have not,
or at least not the same--
[LAUGHTER]
SEAMANS: He doesn't need to.
AUDIENCE: I was curious as to
whether it was accurate at all.
Thanks.
ARMSTRONG: Have you, Buzz?
I can't.
I'm sorry.
I'm a failure.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Armstrong,
I was born in 1973.
I was wondering if you
had any idea or thoughts
to whether people would
be walking on the moon
during my lifetime.
ARMSTRONG: Well,
when I was your age,
I was absolutely certain
that no one would walk
on the moon in my lifetime.
[LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE]
MURMAN: Why don't we take
just one last question
from this gentleman here.
And then we'll wrap it up.
AUDIENCE: From the
lecture and from history
it was pretty clear
that lots of systems
were being tested at
once, as you described.
How did that-- the people in
the program and the pilots--
how did that approach to
testing, not maybe rigorously
testing each system
independently,
how did you react to that?
What was the reaction
inside the program to that?
SEAMANS: I think--
ARMSTRONG: I'll talk
first, and then you can.
SEAMANS: All right.
ARMSTRONG: That's a
perceptive question.
Those of us who
had been involved
in test flying for some
period of time before this
had become advocates of
the step at a time system
that Dr. Seamans discussed.
And it was difficult for
us to accept the idea
that we were going to test
everything at the same time.
Past experience with
that kind of thing--
and in the aeronautical
business, some of you
will know that when you
fly a new airplane that
also has a new engine and also
has a new autopilot and stuff,
you usually have
a lot of problems.
Because you like to
have something solid.
Nevertheless, what
we didn't appreciate
at that point in time was the
increased confidence level
that could be achieved by very
diligent component testing
and systems testing
before we got to flight.
And that was a level
of concentration
that we had not been exposed to
and didn't previously recognize
the value of.
SEAMANS: Well, I can't
speak to the pilot's view
of all up system testing,
but it really became obvious
that we were not going
to be able to proceed
to a final conclusion
of the program
by just putting on a stage,
and then testing it, and then
another stage, and
flying it, and so on.
But I would say that we didn't
shift over in desperation.
I mean, we felt that we were
taking a reasonable risk.
We obviously carried out
that first Saturn V flight
without anybody aboard.
We weren't going to
go to that extreme.
But the component testing,
it was obviously important,
but the really, I
think, important testing
that had not really
been done so extensively
before was done down at the
Mississippi test facility,
where we were able
to take a whole stage
and fire up all the engines.
And you have to realize
that when you did that,
you had to control 7 1/2
million pounds of thrust.
And that was a pretty
gigantic test facility.
But we were planning
to do that anyway.
And by increasing the
level of that testing,
we certainly had a
lot more confidence
that what we were
doing was correct.
But I'll have to say that--
particular that German team--
were quite dubious about it.
And they could not
believe it when
that Saturn V, the
very first one,
went all the way downrange to
where it was supposed to go
and everything fired the
way it was supposed to.
It was a major accomplishment.
It's possibly just
a little bit lucky,
but that's also important
when you're running a program.
[APPLAUSE]
MURMAN: I certainly sense that
the audience is joining me
in thanking our speakers today
and our distinguished guests,
a number of whom I have not had
a chance to introduce to you
that are in the audience
that contributed heavily
to the Apollo program.
You've been a
wonderful audience,
and thank you very
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]